1 decision that has to be made early on in the interpretation of a server
is whether or not to use parallel computing.
There are a range of ways for doing so
and all of these can be combined with each other.
We have vector units on the CPU,
which are units that can operate on vectors;
apply the same operation to say, 4 different values, at the same time.
Multicore CPUs allow us to do several very complex things at the same time.
The same is true for multiprocessor systems.
GPUs, graphics chips, are optimized for working with huge arrays of pixels,
but they can work with everything else as well.
Which means, of course, they are also good at working with matrices.
It's rather difficult to speed up servers for ordinary differential equations.
The server does 1 step at a time,
and every following step depends on the step before.
How could you do some of these in parallel?
That does not seem to work well.
Speeding up a differential equation server for ordinary differential equations
with the help of parallel computing may work,
for instance in a situation where you have lots of isolated entities
which rarely influence each other, such as the planets orbiting the sun.
As you have seen in unit 6, it's of vital importance
to speed up servers for partial differential equations.
And in this case, parallel computing really comes to help.
1 option for this is to use spatial subdivision.
Each processor of a multicore system can handle its own spatial domain.
Treating the borders between the different domains right requires communication.
This can become an expensive overhead.
We'll look into that in the next quiz.
When we apply finite elements or work with implicit servers
for partial differential equations, we often find huge matrices.
They are an ideal workload for GPUs.